few franchises have experienced a kind
of glow up that suicide squad has
the 2016 film was supposed to factor
heavily into the ever-evolving dc
extended universe the original plan was
an all-out war between the justice
league and dark side
needless to say those plans faltered a
bit and suicide squad is generally seen
by many as a misfire in the lead-up to
zack snyder's grand plan
when looking at the movie's rotten
tomatoes scores from both critics and
audiences
it's clear many people didn't care for
the anti-heroic storyline
the team has had numerous successful
plots in the comics but in this instance
it just didn't translate to the big
screen
so that's it what we some kind of
suicide squad
after the film's release many wondered
what the future of the anti-heroes
looked like
and the answer turned out to be not
quite a reboot not quite a sequel but
we're just kind of forgetting about that
first outing
directed by guardians of the galaxy's
james gunn 2021's the suicide squad did
a complete 180 in terms of quality
this film is certified fresh on rotten
tomatoes with the consensus being that
this is the sort of zany gory adventure
people expect out of something titled
suicide squad it's a fantastic viewing
experience for comic book fans and
casual moviegoers alike
however now the question arises what
does the future hold for the franchise
after all if the series can come back
from the first film surely warner
brothers will want to move full speed
ahead on another installment
warner brothers has yet to officially
announce a follow-up to the suicide
squad the studio is likely waiting to
see how it performs at the box office
and how many people watch it on hbo max
if everything lines up a sequel
announcement should be imminent but fans
will still have to wait for the time
being
it certainly seems as though warner
brothers is confident the movie will be
a hit
an hbo max original series centered on
peacemaker is already in the works and
there's always a possibility other
characters could receive spin-offs in tv
series
while everything is still in the dark
for the time being james gunn seems
assured more suicide squad is on the way
the filmmaker spoke with entertainment
weekly in the lead-up to the film's
release
mentioning how he's willing to return to
the sandbox not only that but he offered
this little tidbit too
i've had ideas actually if i did a
sequel it's not like hey let's assemble
another team and let's do this
it would be very different gun remains
silent on what exactly a sequel would
look like but judging from the
consistent quality
process guardians and galaxy films it
would definitely defy expectations
there are plenty of stories from task
force x that could serve as a third
suicide squad movie
task force x has been around in the
comics since 1959 though most are
familiar with the version that arose in
the 1980s
the best part is that the squad
maintains a rotating roster of super
villains so there are other characters
to pull from even if several die in one
movie
it would also be pretty cool of future
suicide squad movies incorporated
villains initially introduced in other
dc movies
for example kristen wiig's cheetah from
wonder woman 1984 could return as a new
team member
it's also important to remember what
james gunn said about a potential sequel
if warner brothers wanted to go a
different route in terms of story the
comics hold plenty of answers
and there's one arc in particular that
would make for an intriguing cinematic
adaptation
burning down the house is a suicide
squad story written by rob williams and
illustrated by john ramita jr it's a
superhero tale combined with a whodunit
that focuses on amanda waller's death
a lot of characters would have liked to
see her bite the dust and it comes down
to some unlikely villains to figure out
who was behind the hit
that's just our pitch and james gunn's
story could be something entirely
different
or someone new could come on board to
lead the squad in an alternate direction
anything's possible but we have a
feeling the suicide squad as a franchise
won't bite the dust anytime soon
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
dc movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one